the Star Wars prequels get a very bad
rap and arguably they probably should
but when I ask people to rank their Star
Wars movies a lot of times they put the
Phantom Menace at the very bottom and I
don't think it's the worst one here's
why one hey it's an excellent drinking
game have your friends over drink
anytime they say trade tax or Federation
you're going to need to call a cab it
gets really ugly in there if you really
want to take it from six to midnight
anytime you see a hologram good night
bye see ya second of all Darth Maul is
an awesome villain yes he should have
been the villain throughout the entire
prequel trilogy but no he gets cut in
half it sucks George why speaking of
Darth Maul duel of the fates stuff up
pop-up pop-up bump up some people like
to point out that the acting is terrible
and yes sometimes it is but here's the
thing these are Oscar caliber actors
that had to stand in a balloon room and
just pretend that things were happening
around them there's some
behind-the-scenes footage of Natalie
Portman just running up and down and
jumping over this blue stick while
chasing a tennis ball that George Lucas
has on a stick it's ridiculous but I
cannot defend Jar Jar Binks or 10 or
medical or games do you like the Phantom
Menace probably not but are there things
about it that you like let me know on
Twitter or in the comments below hit
subscribe wherever subscribe is hit that
and then follow follow us for more
updates i'm going to be at the Star Wars
Celebration in Europe so you can come to
ET for all the big updates follow me on
Twitter for all the little tiny details
that you probably never wanted to know
but I'm going to post them anyway